this is the Great Barrier Reef and it's
dying less than 20 years ago the world's
largest living structure looked like
this and this but today ongoing
pressures from climate change put it at
serious risk for being wiped out
entirely
in fact in August an official report by
the Australian Government downgraded the
reefs future outlook from poor to very
poor so how exactly did we get here
and can it be reversed the Great Barrier
Reef is big so big in fact that you can
see it from space it's important for
people to remember that the Great
Barrier Reef is much more than just one
coral reef which is what I think a lot
of people think so it's actually three
thousand separate individual coral reefs
and every one of them is in a different
condition it's also the world's largest
living structure as well as a home to
thousands of plant and animal species
like with trees in a forest the corals
are really the foundation of the
habitats they provide structure for
other organisms to live there
a normal healthy coral reef is very
colourful there's tons of fish swimming
around it's often quite loud underwater
when you're diving on a coral reef
that's healthy you know it's just
amazing and beautiful but this vast
ecosystem has been declining for a while
the culprit mass coral bleaching as the
name suggests coral bleaching strips
reefs of their color
leaving them completely white it happens
when unnaturally warm ocean water causes
coral to expel the symbiotic colorful
algae it needs to survive without this
algae eat the coral can't get the
nutrients it needs and will starve to
death if water temperatures don't return
to normal even small increases in
temperature when they're sustained for a
long period can be very stressful for
them just like a person right like you
can go out into a 114 degree weather for
a short time and you'll be fine but if
you were to stay out there all day you
would suffer badly in 2016 and 2017
the Great Barrier Reef was hit with a
massive marine heat wave leading to the
longest coral bleaching events ever
recorded it devastated the reef killing
off nearly 50% of the coral many corals
can live for hundreds of years so if
those corals die to get back a core hope
that was 400 years old and died is gonna
take 400 years but here's the thing this
rate of bleaching is not only abnormal
but completely unprecedented in the
Great Barrier Reef's history we have to
remember that the Great Barrier Reef is
now essentially a changed ecosystem
we've never had events as severe as
those of 2016 and 17 before the
cumulative consequence of all of that is
that we don't know how well the Great
Barrier Reef is going to recover from
those events before the 1980s bleaching
events would occur periodically but
never on a mass scale the global warming
has rapidly accelerated this process
from those coral skeletal records we
know conclusively that coral bleaching
is a new phenomenon the first mass
bleaching event that occurred on the
Great Barrier Reef was in 1982 as
bleaching events are becoming more
severe and more frequent it it's
diamonds the recovery right it's almost
as if you you have a hurricane start to
rebuild and then you get hit by another
one in fact a 2019 report by the United
Nations or that if global temperatures
increased by just 0.9 degrees Celsius
which is expected to happen
coral reefs could decline by 70 to 90
percent and if it warms by 1.8 degrees
99 percent of the world's coral could be
at risk
as we approach 2 degrees of warming and
go beyond 2 degrees of warming we are
probably not going to be able to protect
the Great Barrier Reef anymore and we're
actually going to lose it as the
valuable ecosystem that we have as if
that wasn't enough the reef is also
endangered by local pollution
overfishing and coastal development
local management of impacts such as
pollution and Brana
sedimentation in our reads overfishing
these things are critically important
and they need to happen in concert with
combating climate change it's also
important to note that the Great Barrier
Reef is one of the best managed reefs in
the world but even with the best
countermeasures the Great Barrier Reef
simply can't withstand the effects of
climate change unless drastic
international action is taken to reverse
or halt greenhouse gas emissions you
might be facing a world without reefs as
early as 2050 my ballpark is if we don't
do something dramatic in the next 10
years
that we will have passed the time after
which there will be no return so this
all sounds pretty bad but why should we
care what makes coral reefs so important
first of all coral reefs are an
incredible source of biodiversity in
fact they provide a home for 25% of all
marine life even though they take up
just 1% of the ocean floor so we have
six of the world's seven species of
turtles dugongs whales dolphins seabirds
one and a half thousand species of fish
there are also worth billions of dollars
in economic value the Great Barrier Reef
alone brings in over 6 billion in
tourism each year and reefs provide a
natural buffer from violent storm waves
preventing property damage and loss of
life reefs are an increasingly important
resource for breakthrough medical
treatments - right now plants and
animals found in coral reefs are being
used to develop treatments for diseases
like cancer and Alzheimer's so if we
lose corals we potentially lose you know
the key to solving diseases that we care
about
not to mention about half a billion
people depend on reefs for food and work
but even though some of the damage is
irreversible not all hope is lost for
the world coral reefs Wiens a coral reef
science community are becoming
increasingly focused on human
intervention in you know basically
preventing the extinction of corals and
restoring reef
the most important thing that we need to
do is to stop and reverse climate change
and global warming
you